es ist einfach die schere stein papier
das der partie
okay dachte du musst was anderes neben
dem du noch was anderes wie nebenbei was
anderes
okay ist ein papier dass sein papier ist
papier das so wird das nie was ich bin
schon seit 60 stunden und es ist immer
noch unentschieden
aber was denkst du denn dass die antwort
einfach in der flasche aus dem meer her
geschwungen kommt ja irgendwo
wow
[Musik]
fabian berger ja wir haben sie gefunden
was sie haben die geheime farbe für die
kronberger nicht daher ernst soll er
kann nicht kochen also brauchen wir dich
ich mache die bucht und später die bucht
und spielt und auch gekommen lasst uns
alle 2010 suchen jetzt
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen für fällt
heute mit john mayer beiden ihr habt mir
die geheime geheimformel von spongebob
schwammkopf camberger gebracht das
bestgehütete geheimnis der wasserwelt ja
unter wasser ist der unterwelt und wir
drei haben uns hier im youtube space in
berlin jetzt getroffen und zwar aus
folgendem grund wir hatten hunger und
sie können gut kochen und die beiden
kennen sich gut mit filmen serien filme
machen mit allem aus deswegen aber
gedacht für alle match mit allem
natürlich wieder außer kochen aber dass
länder heute dürfen wir heute glaube ich
musste ja und ich lerne bisschen mehr
über filme und serien symbiose ihr tut
ja auch ein bisschen schauspielern nicht
selber so wenn ihr eure kurzfilme mayor
schon eigentlich vielleicht kann ich ja
auch was lernen denke denke wir kriegen
das hin
ich kann nicht schauspieler vielleicht
aber wenn wir mal ein koch in dem film
brauchen dann tust du einfach so als
würdest du kochen ja und dann hast du
gesagt ja
oder sie kann auch wirklich kochen ich
hab' ich habe mir tatsächlich überlegt
eigentlich mal witzig wenn ich eine böse
rolle hätte aber da gibt es eine
problematik ich habe mal einen film
geschaut und und ich war echter totale
mark ruffalo fern mega und in dem einen
film hat er seine frau betrogen und
seitdem passe ich hab ihn nicht aber er
kann noch mister höhe
ja aber die rolle war halt so aber kennt
ihr das nicht also bei euch nicht so
wenn ihr dann ein film schaut und dann
denkt er so he bis dahin war mir der
schauspieler sympathisch ab das ist ein
frauen ding
naja ich dazu emotional nicht glauben
was würdest du geheim halten wenn du
böse wichtig das würdest du einfach zu
viel salz immerhin 13 machen ja bald den
kuchen vor der nase weg essen
dass das erste simpson das könnte ich
nicht nein
okay okay doch solange du sagst was wir
tun und wir tun dass rein gucken
ok brötchen käse salat partie ketchup
senf tomaten käse brötchen und genau in
der reihenfolge in der reihenfolge kann
manchmal auch quallen gelee darauf dass
das war die special edition
ich wollte heute nein heute nein so die
veranstalter ok ich würde sagen wir
fangen mit den brötchen an
dafür brauchen wir wir machen hefeteig
also wir brauchen hilfe etwas zucker
wasser eigentlich buttermilch ich nehme
jetzt meldet weil wir keine butter milch
haben das geht auch gut
weiche butter und mehl das sind alles
zutaten nur fürs brot du kannst
natürlich auch brötchen kaufen aber
selbst gemacht dass selbst gemacht ein
bisschen zu viel zeigt also hatten wir
schon mal sowas bedient ich habe schon
mal gesehen
ja ich war dabei als das gesehen hat ja
es war es patrick es gut dass wir jetzt
ein griff dann machst du dir so nach
oben nachdem texas chainsaw massacre
glaube ich nicht das ist die falsche
kategorie herren traten ja okay machen
jetzt einfach die zutaten genau wasser
hefe zucker am besten zuerst dass der
gesamte inhalt ja okay von allen
abgewogen
das hätte frage ja nie bei ja das kenne
ich halt nicht aus das werde ich noch
oft genug heute sagen die zwei dem
wasser kommt rein und woher weißt du
dass das zucker und nicht als ist weil
zucker mehr glänzt oh mein gott das ist
der trick
weil die ja weißt du wie auch das
unternehmen mit salz getrunken habe ja
es war es ja und in chemie wurden wir
damals in der siebten klasse gefragt
wenn man zucker und salz vermischt wie
kriegt man es auseinander und ich war
die einzige die die antwort wusste weil
ich immer schon gekocht und gebacken
habe und wir kriegen uns auseinander
wenn man zusammen ist kann schon hier
und was er auch das ist meines wissens
liegt ja und dann hängst du film run mit
unterschiedlicher faser dichte und dann
passiert noch etwas hat sich der
intelligente nein da gibt es einfach in
die pfanne und schmilzt ist denn salz
schmilzt nicht und zucker karamellisiert
aber dann kommt ja das macht dann der
rest machte chemiker und das bürgerbus
rezept ist einfach mein grundrezepte
können da in der app mal nachschauen
denn ich glaube es born spruch benutzt
das auch ganz auf ihr wieder einen
schritt weiter okay aber ihr könnt ja
schonmal mehl dazugeben salz solcher mal
einfach das den gesamten inhalt haben
hier kannst du mal so eine handvoll
übrig lassen
eine handvoll in der schüssel ok nichts
mit meiner hand gut alles sicher gehen
eine handvoll übrig lassen ja aber wir
werden schon gleich kneten
ich habe gestern bei 200 grad im ofen
ist es dann auch egal
das ist immer mein 5
ich habe irgendwie angst ich auch so ich
mache erst mal so nicht also halbwegs in
ordnung ja das war so viele sind es
nicht eine handvoll übrig ein bisschen
mehr kälte sind so dahinter folgt also
eine hand rolle in der schüssel lassen
eine handvoll verschütten ist auch ich
hoffe schüttet nein ich mir hier ein
captain das nämlich ganz heißer klar
also nicht heiß aber war das ist nur
etwas ok stand hier noch salz dazu die
eier dazu der heber fühlt sich wohl
ja das geht die wollten gerade testen
zuschauer zuhause aufpassen
ja es geht los die butter kannst du auch
eingeben
nein das schaffst du var
sehr gut habt ihr schon mal burger bank
wir haben natürlich mit den worten du
hast dir meins berger ist selber belegt
war ja dass wir das übermorgen sollten
wir noch in die bürger waren server
gebracht er hat gesagt er kann nicht
kochen und backen
also schließt das habe ich nicht gehört
hat sich noch mehr bürger gebrauch
vielleicht ja cool reimon ja aber das
sehr gut wieder aus matschig und durch
das ist eigentlich so wie lange wie
lange lassen wir das laufen und also
normalerweise mit der hand dass man den
so fünf bis zehn minuten
das war wirklich schön geschmeidig wird
wir machen jetzt wir machen jetzt so 34
minuten bereich und jetzt nur so viel
mehl das praktisch schöner geschmeidiger
teig entsteht nicht so weit nicht
zutreffe
und er löst sie stammen wenn er fertig
ist vom schüssel rammt also da man
erkennt sie an dass der täter gefasst
gut man sieht schon der löst sich schon
ein bisschen ja und am anfang gibt man
immer meist so viel mehr sondern wird
aber zu hart und so setzt aber wenn er
lange genug nähte geht dort nicht mehr
lohne zu bringen
was den film basics die ich auf jeden
fall also ich gucke schon gerne filme
und murat ist wir haben es auch
kennengelernt in der videotheken war
ganz romantisch und der der murat kennt
sich mega gut mit filmen aus aber ich
habe echt viele viele lücken aber was
sind so die top drei filme oder 5 also
da will ich auf jeden fall sagen
interstellar gehört mit zu meinen
lieblingsfilm kennt zudem will das ist
ein film über ja so ein bisschen
gleichzeitig zeitreisen aber auch space
reisen sind film von christopher nolan
und ja der ist der ist also der ist echt
mega durchdacht und es ist cool weil es
halt irgendwo sehr abgespeist und
science fiction ist aber auch
physikalisch sehr gut durchdachtes und
damit auch wirklich an die realität
irgendwo sehr nah dran und auch messer
an realitätsnahe also es ist es ist es
ist eigentlich science fiction aber das
ist sehr realitätsnah ist sich wirklich
an der physik orientiert und nicht
einfach nur irgendwas hier laser das mit
jessica chastain und ich hab gerade
darüber nach wieder welchem film ich
baustelle weil ich hätte gesagt du hast
aber es ist halt genau das gegenteil
das ist krieg und ich werde euch ganz
klein war starb viel arbeit oder so habe
ich das erste mal gesehen und
gleichzeitig einmal anschauen ich wollte
zum beispiel nie twilight gucken weil
ich nichts anfangen kann
es war so werden den in der videothek
alle sind gekommen wir wollen twilight
freilich kommt echt nix mit vampiren
anfangen und irgendwann habe ich mich
überreden lassen ach komm ich gucken an
und jetzt ich habe alle durch will sogar
schon weh und ich habe mir sogar die
bücher bestellt du hast jetzt sogar die
bücher müssen weil die geschichte halten
wenn opel ampera nicht aber die wollen
ja gut aber ich bin team werwolf und
nicht ihm die decke sind verständlich
weil wir einen job bei uns im team haben
dass der sehr mag
hey guck dir mal hat der sieht doch gut
aus sieht der ist noch da aber er klebt
nicht mehr und den lassen wir jetzt
aufgehen so eine halbe stunde bis stunde
und in der zeit können wir schon mal die
krabben bürger zu bereiten
das wird jetzt eine premiere denn
normalerweise mag ich keine
meeresfrüchte also shrimps oder garnelen
das geht mal ganz frisch habe ich auch
schon für das buch gemacht aber
eigentlich bin ich nicht so der
meeresfrüchte fan aber ich hab mir jetzt
gedacht kommen hamburger machen
okay und ich hab aber auch noch fleisch
als wenn wir sagen okay haben bürger
wird nichts denn ich weiß auch nicht wie
es wäre hätten wir eine ganz normale
bürger weil man weiß auch nicht bei
spongebob was ist wirklich drin und weiß
nicht was man behauptet ja so
seepferdchen fleisch aber das ist schon
ein bisschen
das ist ein film über die serie dass
aber die inhaber von dem restaurant
der bus kam ärger gibt ist auch eine
traverse ein bisschen das wäre schon ein
bisschen seine tochter ist auch einmal
von daher sowieso alles
das ist halt echt multikulti oder das
ist multikulti das schau ich meine
tochter mein neuer steller der
hauptdarsteller im schwarm ist noch ein
bester freund wollten sich stern
tatsache gut der teig sieht echt gut als
möglich gelöst
ich hab das verlangen die ganze zeit so
einmal kurz aber er macht auch mist
aber du kannst mal aus du dich schon mal
ein teig reingelegt so eine badewanne
perfekte weg des wildes befürchtet aber
du kannst mal gucken was die konsistenz
ist in ordnung
hast du angst ist der teig eingreifen
nein das nicht aber ich möchte das geht
aus einem türkischen wenn man da so
rezepte nach links die haben einfach
keine waage das ist so ein becher davon
und becher hiervon und dann sagen sie
zum schluss und der teig muss so weich
sein wie das ohrläppchen
aber so was steht man dann sogar es gibt
es so ein universelles ohrläppchen oder
jan ich glaube jeder somit im alter wird
der teig weicher ja das einfach
durchschnitt der türkischen ohrläppchen
ist einfach der maßstab es hat echt so
da kann man sich dann vorstellen wie war
ich der teig ist und was ist die
wartezeit so eine zweite oder wir warten
jetzt einfach 4 t aber wir überbrücken
ja die zwischenzeit mit unseren karten
für die cappenberger nehmen wir 500
gramm cocktail gerne moment mal das sind
doch krabben bürger und nicht garnelen
bürger oder also das ding ist ich habe
es tatsächlich gegoogelt und hier steht
haben sind garnelen der
umgangssprachliche ausdruck graben
bezeichnet meist die nordseekrabben oder
biologisch richtiger die nordsee
garnelen dh krabben und garnelen werden
im allgemeinen sprachgebrauch
unterschieden sind aber dasselbe
herrgott das ist kein problem hätte ich
aber auch nicht gewusst wenn ich nicht
genug ist die sind übrigens tiefgefroren
also die garnelen sind geschält und
gekocht und tiefgefroren
diese chance termin kocht ja deswegen
kannst du die auch im prinzip deswegen
müssen wir nicht die bürger komplett
durchbraten also die sind schon gekocht
und man kann sie so direkt benutzen aus
dem tk hat es gibt eigentlich also für
die camburger brauchen wir 500 gramm
cocktail garnelen eine zwiebel und
knoblauchzehe wir haben 400 gramm mehl
auf zwei schälchen weil es nicht in eins
gepasst hat salz pfeffer 2 eier und
etwas thymian und das bad muss habe ich
nicht dabei aber hätte aufnehmen können
wir nehmen jetzt mit film insidern kommt
kann ich gar nicht ist das kennen wir
das schauspielern blende ich kenne
bradley cooper und das wars
daher muss man auch gar nicht hin mark
ruffalo war vergangenheit
[Gelächter]
lieblingsschauspielerin steht die
schauspielerin jessica gar nichts
jazzige jessica biel ist gut
aber ich wollte sagen denn verloren
ich bin zum beispiel wurde von panik
spezialkenntnissen genau wie hast du
noch nicht gesehen
ich sage es längst ich kann mir
vorstellen was dir gefällt weil du
worauf wartet ganz gut fasst ja also was
finde ich noch gut was findest du noch
gut
unsere einstellung werden wir natürlich
nicht mehr braucht so erhalten die
cooper und unseren das ist alles was du
glaubst also mädels mehr braucht ihr
nicht
habt ihr erst da ist born gesehen hab
ich nicht gesehen kann man nicht hier in
im kino hier drücken dann läuft er noch
aber wer kann so aber im youtube kino
geht das bestimmen also hier stehen wir
ja hier ist doch in youtube space kino
man kann wir uns selber popcorn machen
ich wollte eigentlich dass sie jetzt mag
ich natürlich nicht verletzt ja wissen
wir nicht genau hier wissen wir durch
das sind die drei schiffe hier machen
wir mal den müll rein ist eigentlich
immer auch ganz gut nur beim kochen
immer schöne müll schlüssel zu haben
max ist das schon mal ein ja und ich
habe jetzt leider eigentlich wäre es
echt guten fleischwolf dabei zu haben
denn der fleischwolf zerkleinert einfach
alles haben wir nicht ich probier's
einfach hier in dem handmixer so sind
noch ein bisschen tief gefroren ich
glaube ich muss nicht kurz etwas
aber das geht ganz schnell
ich bin ich suchte schäden ich hab ja ja
ja selbstverständlich habe sie in
scheiben geschnitten soll ich noch
weiter zu halten sagt stüeken der
werkstücke fest dass das zwiebel schälen
und schneiden
der anlass war überhaupt machen youtube
wirklich ja weil im studium habe ich
gemerkt bei dem praxisseminar ja die
haben viele nicht gewusst wie zwiebeln
geschält und es ist einfach so kann ich
verstehen aber du hast es richtig
gemacht
hier oben die wurzel der direktor dran
und das hier und schneidest du weg so
wie du selbst gemacht hat da musste ich
und dann hast du sehen und jetzt hast du
hier oben den part der praktisch
getriebe zusammenhält und kann es jetzt
hier wird's oben rein schneiden aber
nicht komplett durch
dann bleibt sie schön zusammen und fällt
nicht auseinander und ein gleichmäßiger
würfel drehen viele schneiden noch so
aber das brauchst du nicht in die
zwiebel hat geschichten stimmt deswegen
spart man sich das und wenn du dann so
warst hast du viele feine geflogen
dann hätte ich auch gemerkt okay nicht
jeder kann
schneiden und dann habe ich auch die
tipps die muss man weitergeben
noch mehr freuen konnten aber so nicht
ob gott schneidet ihr auch gottschall
erwarte links hinten liegst ihn nicht in
den finger schneiden ja nicht einfach
einfach mal mit großen messern immer
vorsichtig schneiden und den cullen
griff die zuschauer zu hause die sich
hier mit kochen beschäftigen und mit
sich total einfach nur faul sind die
hier martin knoblauch und weiß mit
firmen aus kann ich alles gut können
okay ich mag übrigens auch die folge von
spongebob mit dem gegenteil tag sommer
gegenteil tag machen bitte schneiden
zwiebeln jetzt nicht oder wie war es
dann das problem wann hört man auch hier
gegenteil ich weiß dann nicht mehr
spielen wir schon spielen wir gerade
nicht was ich meine
also im sinne von sich geben das sind
dass wir nicht gut sieht man die grenze
ja das oder wo man sieht man sie nicht
aber vielleicht wenn man so einen safe
vortrags auf starke bestimmt das safe
hat irgendwann einmal als sehr
vorschnell also wir probieren das herz
das ist
ja das habe ich weiß dass das kein
wettbewerb aber werfen und beiden hat es
besser geschnitten
[Musik]
für beides super und es war die politik
gerichtet und wir haben jetzt echt keine
arbeit mehr mit den garnelen
denn die sind ja schon gestellt und die
wir nur das ist das was wir wollen keine
kleinen menge und dann machst du zehn
rechts den link danach musste ich mir
als kritische logik optimalen das nicht
klappt ja ohne strom
da freut sich davon gestern dessen grün
den wir doch da getroffen haben ich habe
mir gesagt das schafft ihr oder kommt
ganz darauf an was du bist also noch
hier die garnelen
ja komm jeder von euch darf hier mal zu
halten
es gab echt von wunderbaren kollegin und
ich rate euch immer von rechts den links
und dann okay ist so ausgeglichen
ja man werde ich dass der eine bizeps
größer wird das der anderen also
du kannst du mal die zwiebeln auch dazu
machen und die knoblauchzehen also wir
müssen da jetzt echt so ein bisschen
herum experimentieren denn ich habe das
noch nicht aber ich glaube ich glaube
dass herumexperimentieren jetzt schon
dass mir das noch ein bisschen gutes
licht auf jeden fall ja nie wissen kann
er ja eigentlich schon also es ist jetzt
mein leibgericht aber eigentlich wollte
ich mein leibgericht aber woher bürger
ist dass ich glaube berge dabei bürger
würdest du das vielleicht nicht so drin
ist es wahrscheinlich ja ich war mal bei
wir sind ja aber natürlich ein bisschen
mehr passt ist die schlimmste im film
vorkommen kannst du sagen okay weil der
halter sind da trifft er auf jemanden
der sich viel mit schlips auskennt und
am ende machen macht ein restaurant in
seinem namen auf und da hab ich das ist
schon gegessen habe ganz schön feist das
habe ich noch hier sagt decker
also wäre das nächste doch der ausflug
vielleicht habt ihr auch noch
rezeptideen als wären wir online wenn
man das hobby in abstimmung gemacht
welchen film es nochmal machen und
deswegen also von euch kamen die
vorschläge spongebob und viele andere
transporters dachten wir so dass keine
jobs gibt glaube ich muss doch mit
rechts weitermachen ja haben sie keine
zeit zu kochen und ins fitnessstudio zu
gehen
mit dem neuen handspring mixa 3000
schaffen sie alles in einem heim
sehen sie gut aus und essen sie leckere
sogleich schön cremig aus
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
aber ja mit dem kannst es ausschaut und
ich würde schon mal mit seinem verein
mir dann kannst es außerdem fasziniert
also ich koche auch recht viel aber das
haben sie ja ne liste was wir alles so
irgendein utensilien alles professionell
ich mache alles in der küche mit einer
gabel und löffel kannst ja unseren
schlagen wichtiger ist hast du gute
zutaten haben werkzeug ist nicht so
wichtig gute zutaten so wichtig diese
werkzeuge helfen die helfen die iss und
manfred sich so ein bisschen besser wenn
ich koche halt auch viel und wacker viel
und deswegen ist für mich schon werkzeug
wichtig sonst kommen wir nicht herum mit
der zeit
okay sie prinz in den knoblauch ist drin
garnelen spricht oder salz pfeffer mail
machen wir jetzt noch dazu warum mir wow
er kocht ab und zu in die eier auch zum
binden und die schnürsenkel auch zu
bisschen trainieren nicht so viel und
jetzt darfst du gerne also kann es auch
kneten rühren
hast du eine röhre technik ok nach
darwin recht machte das irgendwie
seltsam aber ich glaube ich bleibe
erstmal beim landkreis
ich glaube wir brauchen noch etwas mehr
denn momentan ist noch bis hin zu max
noch ein bisschen mehr dazu geben würden
aber ich glaube also einen großteil
beschlossen stück zwiebel ist dass wir
uns nicht von mir
jay macht das so als hätte er noch nie
in seinem leben etwas anderes
ja ich bin ja auch schauspieler zu tun
als ob ich weiß wovon ich rede
wir brauchen mehr mail
die farbe ist gar nicht so schlecht gehe
karotten weiß prof du magst dann was wir
was wir jetzt den nächsten schritt
machen so wie wir werden jetzt die
bürger pettys formen und dann einfrieren
von einfrieren
also mache ich mit fleisch fleisch
butter pettys immer so wie man die sich
damals ergründen lassen
und ich denke bei denen ist auch nicht
schlecht wenn man es mal gucken ob ich
den aktionären dabei haben weil dann
kann man so schön portionieren dorstens
ich bin wieder da
[Gelächter]
sag mal wenn wir zurückspulen würden
würden wir sehen dass das thema wir
spielen aber nicht zurück ok jede wette
dass das orion 114
ok dann werde ich mit dir oben fünf euro
machen wir 10
ihm ist es sogar noch selber aufgefallen
war
ich habe das video durchgeschnitten also
ich habe jetzt den eisplatz lehrer
verkehr also das spannendste irgendwie
finde ich die ganze zeit herauszufinden
was sie hier fiel das beispiel was ist
das ist es jeder verdient war ja das ist
ja cool dann muss man solche
wegschmeißen eigentlich wirklich führen
ich hoffe das klappt so dachte ich nicht
mal so weit ich das nicht okay aber wir
fragen sie doch ein
aber so ist eine form des weges
geschafft jetzt meine eis portionierer
nicht dabei aber so
hatten wir salz ja sie hat ganz viel
reingemacht ganze magst du dich mal dran
ich hoffe du kannst ja gleichsam zum
mehl drüberstreuen ja so ein kurs
draußen kann ich machen aber wir haben
ja noch ein bisschen was
also wenn ich das jetzt als normales
rezept videos so gemacht hätte ich
glaube das halte ich auch vorher
ausprobiert normalerweise mache ich
alles im video so zum ersten mal
schreibt die zutaten hin meist passt das
aber meeresfrüchte da bin ich so drüber
wie bisschen panade außenrum magst du
das machen na klar auch ein kann ich
hier den job machen das ja ein bisschen
vielleicht kannst du hier sogar ein
bisschen mehl darauf streuen informa den
direktor
ich glaube das ist ein guter typ ist ein
kleiner machen oder passt
ich glaube im übrigen ist er der mologen
wir sagt man einen kleinen so dann mach
das mal wenn du hier auch mehr drauf
machst
zwischen sehr gut und so fahren wir
jetzt weiter und dann kommen die erst
mal in den gefrierschrank und haben
burger teig jetzt soweit ich weiß ich
bin ein morgen deswegen wie ich immer
die brötchen ab 80 gramm kann also
gedruckt ihren ja jahrelang fenja 85.500
lieblingsziel nicht schlecht
81 81 wer möchte wiegen
na gut dann macht er ist also 68 81 ist
okay so ein bisschen abwägen
genau das auch immer so und der
wahrnehmung
dann könnt ihr mal die hände so ein
bisschen fetten wo ich zeige euch jetzt
wie wir daraus schöne brötchen formen
okay und zwar immer von außen nach innen
und das praktisch fast zurück außen
nimmt dann hast du nämlich hier eine
glatte oberfläche bis in die hand und
macht noch den darm
ich weiß nicht ob mir das zu viele
schritte sind aber ich werde probieren
ja erstmal hände einfetten meinst du
haben wir hier fällt zum einen vierten
also ich jetzt hier so ein
du kannst auch auf der arbeitsfläche
machen hier ist alles antwort ja
guck mal da und das ist der wahnsinn
sagte dem mund gerissen
ich habe diese immer mit meiner mama ich
habe morgen geliebt und ja alle regler
wohnung ziehen
und ich war so als ich das gesehen habe
wusste ich ich bin normal denn wenn es
noch menschen gibt er sein damit sich
eine serie darum dass wir nicht nochmals
aber ich habe ich fand es schon normal
naja aber noch bis nach der serie konnte
ich begründen warum ich meine
zuckerstraße nach farbe sortir du das
gemacht
ok wenn du zu gast
das stimmt ich mache das auch mit sich
dass man die auch wenn der einzelnen
farbe kaufen können ja bei uns kann man
im supermarkt sind ja da kann man auch
die hat sich also im moment ja ich hab
ein ganz kurz welche farbe braun weil
dies ohne künstliche farbstoffe nehme
ich meine nicht welche farbe sondern
welche sorte
damit müsse mit erfolg und mit die mit
atmos weise können vom blieb ein miterbe
und natürlich muss das kenne ich aber
nicht sie kennst du dich
ach so ja okay dann verstehe ich dein
vierte aber wenn man mal so schaut sind
die eminems gar nicht also ich finde es
dennoch so die beste süßigkeit die man
essen kann weil dort praktisch viel
erdnuss bisschen schokolade und dann so
ein bisschen zucker überzeugt also
besser als so ein gummibärchen
das kann sein so im vergleich gab es ja
ich glaube ich hab's nicht ganz so gut
erdachte sehr gut ausnutzt reeßum ok
umgedreht schwarz wir uns umdrehten ist
die gute seite hat sich
nein es geht gut auskommen müssen und
jetzt ich glaube die fans einfacher wenn
du es auch hier auf der arbeitsfläche
ist also auch hier die ja natürlich
meine ich geb dir mal den teig hier raus
weil hier weg dann kannst du dich die
spachtelmasse und dann guckt so und
deine finger tun von außen praktisch so
du musst ja forschern als würdest du die
oberfläche so nach unten schieben
ach ja das spürst du das so ist der
krebs nicht schlimm wir haben genug teig
ja ja ja ja sie irgendwann ja na gut wir
haben einfach zu den anderen und
vielleicht ja nicht auf nach irgendwo
einfach mal rein weißen alles
auseinander
mensch leute gut aus ehrlich dafür dass
so dass zum ersten mal ehrlich so nett
immer das ist sehr ungewohnt aber danke
gesagt
doch die wahrheit gesagt
hier ist alles in ordnung aber was du
machen kannst
ja du kannst jeder auf das blech legen
sich wie kam es zu schauen während die
politik hier drei mal vier okay das
kriege ich hin aber begreift ihr messen
nimmst du eine tankkarte chefs das motto
runter dann macht es ziemlich kaputt
dass das macht sie muss ist ja und dann
kannst du dir so schön bunt wie sie sind
so aufs gleiche gleiten lassen und dann
willst du ein bisschen mehr und sagt ach
drücken denn im ofen gehen die sowieso
wieder auf ok danach fällt echt nicht
mehr auf mit einem bildschirm wie gesagt
hätte ich sehr nett deswegen ja aber ich
werde darüber weil ich freue sie dass
ich bisschen bisschen mehr drauf war das
richtig gut so auf deine hände
das machte ich finde wir könnten
wirklich so eine krosse krabbe
das gibt es doch gar nicht sein laden
das wirklich die krosse krabbe wäre ja
stimmt also zumindest nicht offiziell
darauf aufmerksam machen dass gerade so
ein bisschen so aussieht als wäre für
die brötchen trösten
also ich will es einfach nur nicht
arbeit gut mache dies fängt schon einmal
nein sagst du dir vielleicht einfach
aufs blech legen
okay das sind keine 80 gramm
das sind 70 oder 60 siehst du auch alle
anderen mann 80 hätte das ist eine
produktionslinie des klaren sätzen
maximal das andere black na klar
man lege ich dir drauf und wollen wir
das schon geben glaubt auf so gut
dasteht wirklich 80 kommen nun ja ist es
nicht
warum sagst du dass du ihren effekt
jetzt denken die leute dass ich weiß gar
nicht mehr was dann ja vielleicht wenn
du dir noch flach ich weiß gar nicht ich
guck mal hier finde dein brötchen ok
liebe zuschauer dass du vielleicht
herausfinden wachsen wir mal einen blick
darüber geben ja klar so effekt die
brötchen sind jetzt getröstet er und und
wir machen das jetzt so wer
normalerweise lasse ich die noch mal
aufgeben so eine halbe stunde haben wir
noch luftiger und schiebt sie dann in
den heißen backofen wir bestreichen sind
noch mit eigelb und wasser damit sie
glänzen ein bisschen sesam drauf hat
punkte höher so die leicht freundliche
farbe jetzt also nicht durch zugerufen
sie werden wieder vergessen haben
sondern durch schon mal scheint habe ich
nicht genug
das ist nahe getreten und gehört das
passt schon
die sind nur wieder hoch und wir machen
es so wir werden jetzt etwas zeit sparen
wir bestreichen zugleich bestreuen sie
mit sesam da kommen sie den kalten
backofen wir heißen ofen vor
also wir machen dann den ofen an und
während der ofen aufheizt gehen die
brötchen auch auf unseren sport und
danach werden sie direkt mit butter
bestrichen damit sie noch so weit ist
muss ich bleibe also hole ich ein eigelb
und wasser und ihr dürft sprechen
das hat jetzt keinen pinsel haben machen
wir hier so die street formel 1 keinen
pinsel also mach es doch bloß ein
bisschen drüber und dann verteilt sodass
das hat ein team das mit normaler löffel
hier machen das freiwillig und sprechen
kannst auch auf den löffel verzichten
und einfach das geht natürlich auch ihr
körper nicht machen darf ich hier
einfach weghaben bürger saison brötchen
wird wenn ja wieviel saison weil wir
haben saison machen ja wir machen sie
denn wie viel sie dann darfst du
entscheiden gut
ihr habt ihr krabbenfang mal gelesen ja
stimmt und die geheime was dachte wir
improvisieren hier noch ein bisschen ja
na gut dann eine halbe gerade ich weiß
immer noch nicht wer jetzt bald schon
hat einen bridge so
perfekt wird
es ist wirklich perfekt wir müssen nur
noch überlegen nach dem backen wie wird
es mit der heißen butter dann machen
dann stelle ich mir meine finger nicht
in den buchhandel ist aber die riesen
wir dann einfach drüberfahren gesagt
aufs wechsel kommt es nicht an
das stimmt jürgen auf die guten zutaten
und ich will mir das jetzt oder erst
nach oben herab die kochen sondern nur
auf die guten lehrmeister kretz wäre
stolz auf uns und die britin wird von
uns bestimmt sicherheit die in diesen
jetzt auch viel zu teuer für mich sogar
zwei wir so lange brauchen egal
die brötchen kommen jetzt in den kalten
backofen wir machen dann den backofen an
und dann packen sie einfach etwas länger
also auf den block steht weil wir
einfach die aufheizzeit mit nutzen und
dann werden sie hoffentlich wunderschön
aufgehen und dann können wir schon da
drüben die schlimmste die cappenberger
antraten sehr gut macht ihr das fällt
auf dass wir auf alle saison gemacht
haben aber macht man nicht nur sehen wir
haben auf die oberen
das ist was wir haben es durch sam mit
und kochen das nicht meine stärke
oh ja das war so ich dachte da das hast
du nicht ernst gemeint vergessen
aber du kannst du das so machen mit
diesem nein die mitte der 3
das ist das deswegen ist
und da machen wir gleich das gemüse
zwiebeln tomaten oder gurken sondern
alles schneiden ja übrigens so glücklich
2002 sich einstellen anstellen könnte es
ein eigenes format werden weil das war's
also einstellt nur alle voll motiviert
auch noch nicht so schlimm
da sagt man ein gefühl hast du alles
falsch machen auch noch motiviert dabei
sind das ist das was wir gerne zu dass
falsche motiviert kannst du es nicht
auch nicht jetzt hab ich habe ich
versucht auch gar nicht ich will es auch
gar nicht probieren
sally hat mir gerade eine ziemlich
rührende geschichte erzählt und ist dann
einfach gern ich kann ja jetzt nicht
nacherzählen weil das ist sie nicht
privat ist aber es hat absolut nichts
mit dem zu tun
nein stehe problems und zwiebeln ach so
du dich da hin oder wir hier sagte
walser
es reicht wenn du das hier am
schnellsten ja da hast du schon gefehlt
ja manchmal ist es halt einfach noch
eine schale mit abzumachen ja aber es
hat auch verschwunden ok dann ich gehe
aber schnell gut das war mal gut dann
ist ja ich weiß ich weiß auch gar nicht
das ist der beiden ich werde probieren
du findest das einfach du hast ist es
einfach laufen und schoss dann wohin
sich die zwiebel im gegenteil das ding
ist kochen das hat auch nicht meine
stärke gibt keinen plan
da gibt's kein plan da gibt es keine
rezepte das ist einfach schön ja rezepte
sind gefühl ist als auch ansichtssache
im braten oder backen
die habe ich ganz allein gemacht und die
macht jetzt auch noch und macht ihr
gewickelt hh wir sollten sie nicht
würfeln was wirst du schnell nein
scheele die zwiebel denn wir wollen sie
erhoben
nein ich hab jetzt gesagt ich war das
eigentlich aus also jetzt wird es zeit
wirklich gerade gesagt das belegen jetzt
schon ja zu unterscheiden ganz praktisch
nicht einmal sind wir zurück schulen
würden dann würden wir herausfinden das
baby und ich liebe hand sein
ich bin echt begeistert von diesem
küchengerät doch dass man der hand sie
ist aber nicht schlimm
geben wir uns auch für einen salat
morgen also deswegen ist ich mag gerne
in meinem album du bei dir gipfel da
rein sie so mussten die demokratie
das muss echt sagen
ich freue mich jemals doch kamera
gezeigt
liegen die ehemals gezeigt die geheime
geheimformel brötchen käse salat partie
ketchup senf tomaten käse brötchen und
wo warst du ja aber innen sein
das ist einfach immer online seien
tomaten zwiebeln und viel liebe glaubt
geblieben meinen die zwiebel wahnsinn
weil zwiebeln ist liebe ich ziehe mir
bringt dich zum weiß ist gefühlvoll
ebene rechnet liebe also wir brauchen
quasi die trainer in dem eine meiner
tränen ich meistens und gewitzten sind
auch nirgends geschrieben aber ich finde
das kannst du nicht kannst du nicht die
folge von spike ist ohne wird wo das ist
sich der eine beschwerde gegen vergessen
hier hat die kirchen wenn ich deswegen
ich glaube einfach dass die vorne
die würde von kranken gefälscht jetzt
erinnern jetzt eine gurke und super hat
jetzt hast du es drauf ich lieber nicht
denken ja vorbereitungen sind getroffen
[Musik]
man kann sogar die dicke einstellen weiß
gar nicht was ich mit der ganzen neu
dazugewonnenen zeit anfangen ich kannte
schiff zweiter werden und ein buch über
ihn schreiben so hat ihr auch hier
können wir gerne machen wo sind die dann
aber die kicker sein
jetzt kommt meine hände so hätte ich
immer noch von vorhin das parkbad
händewaschen jungs das auto in der küche
was ist es müll entsorgen aufräumen und
dann entsteht nämlich kein chaos in der
küche immer wieder putzen immer wieder
putzen ja okay manchmal noch die gucken
hier rein gelassen ein bisschen dicker
so viel zur krise sowie die 40 grad
damit würde ich sagen braten wir wir
warten noch fünf minuten weil die
brötchen noch kurz brauchen und dann
haben wir alles frisch
[Musik]
also ihr könnt die kosten deshalb gerne
auch back transfer ist rapsöl und
kokosfett hoch erhitzt buchwitz war
super leicht zu dosieren und schön im
abgang
und dann könnt ihr auch in der pfanne
anbraten aber wir nehmen jetzt eine
grillplatte denn spongebob hat auch eine
grillplatte und genommen ja wenn es mal
dran gehen wollen saison auf der anderen
seite unsere brötchen
ich finde man erkennt gar nicht mehr
menschen einst war das ist im moment
[Gelächter]
gerettet die sie noch gut aus also wenn
ich sage euch jetzt ein tipp wenn man
sie aufgehen lässt bevor man sie packt
dann werden sie gleichmäßiger und jetzt
sind sie ein bisschen eingerissen wir
sind weil wir sehr gleich mit bestrichen
haben ja und wenn du eben erst aufgeben
des dann bestreicht und dann war's dann
reißt nicht ab aber wir holen jetzt hier
schnell abhaken
muss dass der roboter abgesagt danke
vielen dank für diesen tipp
da wir den pinsel nicht finden würde ich
sagen ich glaube es das bisschen
offensichtlich wird ja meiners ich habe
schon immer eine frage gehabt ist das
was du immer kocht auch das was ihr dann
ist das heißt mit torten backen an einem
tag das essen wir dann tatsächlich also
ich hab hunger macht deswegen geht es
immer gleich eine riesenportion fürs
team
also weil ich mal kochen war aber das
einzige problem dabei ist halt immer so
die zeit ist er mal findet der anruf ist
kochen ja deswegen kann sein aus der
mittagspause mal um 15 uhr ist ist und
dann ist ja ich kann einen gefallen wir
bestreichen das ist doch mit brutalem
einfach erhält mutter blog ist ein
natürlich nicht aus
naja wie genau hat jetzt einfach so ein
bisschen die sau
ganz vorsichtig nur so ein bisschen dann
kriegen sie wissen kleines bisschen
geschmack und hier drüben die hertha ist
schon heißt sieht es aus wie es von
shops anwender sollte jetzt so drauf
lippen lassen
ich mache das lieber zwei schritten ich
dachte jetzt irgendwie eigentlich
angetriebenen metern alles klar
und ich meine die garnelen die waren
hier als die kappen die sind ja schon
durch gegart das heißt jetzt hier schön
anbraten von allen seiten bis das ei und
so weiter ist schau mal was ich mich
frage ist so eine grillplatte also ich
finde die ziemlich cool weil ich habe
gerne auf dem perry diese grill streifen
darauf aber hat es noch einen weiteren
sinn ist es einfach so damit damit das
nicht an klebt oder so die hitze
verteilt sich ganz gut und einsetzen
kann so eine klatsche platinen ja aber
warum gibt es ist einfach und dann kann
der saft abtropfen
das fett abtropfen das hat mir gerade
überlegt aber ich glaube es ist ganz
logisch irgendwie passiert noch ein
mädel klopp das ist wahrscheinlich auch
weil weil mehr drin ist weil das die
flüssigkeit bindet und dann eben nicht
spritzt er ganz genau das wollte ich
sagen mit der exakt selben gott bands
mit nach hause
ja recht oft nehmen also jetzt nicht
recht auf aber ich mache mehr oder
weniger regelmäßig eigene bürger aber
halt nicht die durch den kanzler auch
gut einfrieren
abkühlen lassen in lose glückwunsch
einfrieren und dann einfach kurz mit
aufbacken
ja perfekt sieht es aus kommen und sich
jeder ein teller und dann erleben sie
gleich oder kann das weg durch das
labertal die ibiza
[Musik]
aber es ist in französisch sind die
bürger wird die schau mich okay aber er
singt das in der deutschen version das
durch mit einer große grabe peter ich
war mit meiner freundin in hamburg oder
haben einfach mehr hamburg
während sie die treppe hoch läuft reißt
ihre hose und ihr wisst was ich dann
getan habe was hast du getan hast du
[Gelächter]
noch mal auf meiner seite
doch da suchten die menschen ganz
schnell das sollte also gerade in den
nächsten wende wenden sich von mir ab
nur weil ich meine hose
du hast du ganz schrecklich
nur weil ich meine hause zf ist
eigentlich voll die kulisse geschrieben
willst du eigentlich so ein zweites mal
unten habe ich werde einmal so tun als
ob ich das jetzt nicht gehört habe und
ja natürlich nehme ich mir noch ein
zweiter natürlich also ich wäre dabei
nicht wirklich an und diese wenn nicht
noch größer wenn man sie vorher noch
aufgehen lässt einnahmen
es kann aber auch sein dass ich als sich
diese folge angeguckt habe unter großen
capital
gerade für französisch gelernt haben und
jetzt der moment
ich hoffe das wird erst wenn ich erstmal
hand
immerhin haben wir beide seiten ganz
kurz sich überlegt aber wir bleiben
schön zusammen ich bin super verwirrt
kennst du das wenn du etwas erwartet und
es trifft dann anders also zum beispiel
wenn du gerade eistee trinkst und denkst
es cola und dann ist da keine kohle da
müssen wir machen jetzt noch dann haben
wir schnell warum hältst du das also
kannst du gern machen weil ich mich hier
raus das ist eigentlich sogar ziemlich
schlau
siehst du musst es wird einfach was ich
sage er hält doch nur das ding fest ok
ja ja ich weiß auch woran das liegt
werden wir dürfen nur zwei herdplatten
besitzen wegen stripperin ja also es
liegt daran muss ich sagen da wir jetzt
die küche im boden hat ein bisserl
improvisiert haben mit der küchenbauer
ist halt so wir haben nicht so viel
strom
daher reicht der strom mit ziemlich viel
kreide herdplatten deswegen aber zu
hause klappt das wunderbar und zu hause
klappt das wunderbar schön kross wie in
der großen komplex timo rath ich fahre
ja eigentlich zu verstehen also
eigentlich
[Musik]
jetzt manchmal war schon ziemlich cool
finde ich auch ein bisschen verstören
darüber aber wenn du mal so dringend ist
dann merkst du richtig bisschen
verstehen und ich finds halt krass immer
noch aktuell ist
er läuft immer noch das ist auch auf die
erfolgreichste nickelodeon serie aber ja
manche folgen manche folgen waren
verstörende als andere glaub ich
wir haben wir haben die garantie darüber
gemacht es gibt ein paar momente
westbahn doch das sind nicht unbedingt
die folgen sondern einfach immer wieder
mal irgendwelche details dazu mit manche
sachen die show im tv anschauen von
denen ich jetzt nicht vor allem
verstehen glaube ich kinder nicht immer
den witz die erwachsenen hören was ganz
anderes raus als die kinder und beide
können darüber lachen kann man es auch
zu sein und schon ein beispiel ich
konnte damit echt nie was anfang aber
ich habe schon gehört
ich habe dort gebacken kriegt ja dann
kriegst du zwei pluspunkte also wir sind
soweit ich habe wenn die burger-kette
ist jetzt einmal verkleinert weil ja die
schrumpfen halt nicht wie fleisch okay
die heime geheimformel wir machen
ach so dass das heißt die reihenfolge
also quasi das kommt auch ganz unten
schauen wir mal kurz ein
es gibt mehrere interpretationen und
manchmal hat auch ein bisschen 4000
machen also hier besteht brötchen petty
und zwiebeln gurken tomaten ketchups
sender kommt nochmal partie denn das
wasser weg salat käse sei es halt so ein
drittel der bürger aber dann wieder bloß
gefunden vielleicht auch einfach
irgendwas im schule aufstieg bleibt
braucht dich so da steht drauf wir
machen jetzt zwar nicht zuerst die angst
der immer sensationell zwischending
zwischen kg weil wir machen komme machen
bei den schwimmverein ich mache was soll
ich machen
ok und man steht nicht mehr jemand
spielt nicht mit billigen trick den
anwender zu wenden und der vettel hat
wieder darauf dass waren elegant kommt
nicht hier und noch das bibel und kirche
okay das heute legen sind einfach nur
wir machen jetzt so aber catcher als
miley smiley
ich weiß einfach über das rad im
ketscher ich wollte eigentlich meinen
laptop mitnehmen einsetzt gemacht würde
ich sehr gerne gegessen
ja ich habe das paar mal auch in
regionen glaube ich wir sehen dann
gesagt gemacht kennt ihr das ist eine
gabe galileo beitrag dazu gesehen ich
kann das
dem messe motto ist einfach mal so dick
sein
wir machen jetzt müssen wir dann nicht
die glöckchen auch mit dem käse zu
denken das soll das nächstes jahr
erwarte die glöckchen haben doch diesmal
dies bekommen glaube ich und dann wurden
sie zu gedenken käse hat das ist dass
uns moldawien sein
und dann hat genau das bottroper rezept
und dann haben sie noch einen
gutenachtkuss von spongebob wechseln
dabei wird es jetzt ein essen küssen was
magst du einfach so ketchup drauf
klecksen wie ich mir auch ein gesicht ja
nur zusammen machen von mir von allen
szenen wo ich hier einfach die
funktioniert ist meine ich weiß was ich
glaube die fleisches kaputt macht du
erst mal und jetzt täglich sieht somit
dem tag lesen 88
komme ich ja mit stempel gemacht aber er
sieht nicht ganz so glücklich aus
irgendwie die spitzen so nach oben das
erlaubt etwa mit der sog
na gut mein burger ist fertig man hat
gesehen dass sie gute runtergefallen ist
okay also erstmal gehen jetzt die
mädchen schlafen und dem nachdenken
sagte zwanziger
ich habe ja aber zwei fertige bürger und
war zutaten die auch gleich soweit sein
und sagen wir nicht nach hause krabbel
bürger aufgewachsen und jetzt müssen wir
ihnen jetzt haben wir den hier warte mal
warum sagst du kannst nimmt immer mein
vater mal wörtlich habe ich sagen moment
mal auf sich zu bewegen
er kann ja sein dass irgendwas ist ich
nicht mein burger ist nämlich noch nicht
geschlossen
sie kommt zwischen 21 und 22 kommt
natürlich noch besondere salat gesunder
salat weil wir nicht mehr lange leben
[Musik]
also wir probieren jetzt lamberger gramm
und 30 21 und ich mal gut ich hab mich
mal gerissen das geht gar nicht fertig
ist
komischerweise schmeckt das nicht so
sehr nach fisch
besonders mit gewürfelten zwiebeln aß
ein echtes schönes erlebnis
ich weiß nicht wie das mit zwiebeln aus
dieser für alle die keinen fleischigen
berger wolle aber auch kein bergfahrer
bist du ein camberger perfekt mir
empfehlen
nachdem ich ein paar selbst gemacht habe
wisst ihr was der krabben darin der
großen grabbe kostet bestimmt einen
dollar 99 jetzt immer noch
verbraucher mit quallen cdu kommt
verfahren mit gerade die ernte aus was
die körper entdeckt also ich finde der
kammer ist richtig gut geworden
danke für eure unterstützung das rezept
findet ihr wie immer in der app oder auf
celtics - blog de oder am see oder am
see vielleicht fliegt schwimmt die
flaschenpost bei euch vorbei miteinander
soll gerne dort war voll cool dass er
dabei war
vielleicht kann könnt ihr mir ein
bisschen so schauspielkünste beibringen
dann wenn ich auch was von euch bekommen
man drüber mit ihr kommt frage werde
eine neue rezept idee habt filmidee
vielleicht habt ihr ideen weil das film
essen wir noch nachmachen können dann
schreibe es in die kommentare und falco
echt gut probiert's aus auch wenn ihr
keinen fisch wein seit bin ich auch
nicht als ich erst schon fisch aber
nicht so gern
das ist nicht nur meine leibspeise aber
das schmeckt richtig gut kommt nicht
mehr
[Gelächter]
die großen haben bürger
machen wir mal
haben wir haben alles okay das wäre dann
erledigt gucken wir wissen dass der film
fehler auf meinem fahrrad ihr habt jetzt
auf meinem kanal ist okay jede wette
dass das aber ich werde mit dir das ok
abgenutzt jetzt mussten
ok ok 10 euro und schau mal nach ok jede
wette dass das gemeinschaftsgefühl war's
denn ich habe das video durchgeschnitten